and grab my arm I looked into my eyes
he's like don't do it
don't do it don't give in to cynicism
don't be pessimistic if you do that they
win that's how they want you if you're
pessimistic if you're cynical they win
because you aren't going to do anything
to change the world it is so important
to to Foster joy and hope and everything
that we do how do we especially engender
that and Inspire that in the younger
generation how do we do that with teens
how do we do that with college kids and
people in their 20s that are lost in
dealing with this rampant Mental Health
crisis that's killing Millions that's
our most important task in front of us